okay fill it in for me guys if we define
FX to be a hyperbola right what an X
then what's F Dash gonna be what's the
derivative going to define that's by
definition first when I write limit yeah
and what well done as H approaches zero
you want to find C all the way around
okay
oh we're so close what am I gonna have
on the D right here I want f of X plus h
write f of X plus h is what on X plus h
do you hear that that's me putting X
plus h into right and I'm going to take
away some I'm working out the rise here
what it X very good that's f of X all
over H okay now before before we were
just dealing with powers of X so is
pretty simple all you need to do on the
numerator was just expand the thing and
just magically simplified out okay when
you do here there's no expansions to do
I'm going to well I've got a number of
choices here right essentially what I
want is to put this into a form that's
gonna get let allow me to get rid of
this right so creases
well it's not it's like irrational we
will get to that we will get to that
okay what it is going to be is if I if I
just add that fraction that pair of
fractions on the top if I just Adam then
this is going to become X on X X plus h
right and this is going to be X plus h
on X X plus h do you agree with that
just come in denominator business all
over H so now when I take the limit
what's happening up there what's
happening I'm going to have X minus X
minus H on X X plus h do you agree that
that's that numerator that's just the
numerator that's being divided by H side
okay just combine the fractions together
all right this is great you see that
that's really good okay it's okay it's
all right
so I've got let's not skip anything here
I've got minus H on X X plus h right
that's my numerator all over H now my HS
can go right this is just like before
the X's did cancel out once I add the
two fractions so I've got the limit and
as H approaches zero all of what if I
got minus 1 on X and now I'm in a
position where I can actually evaluate
and see what happens when H really is
zero okay which is 2 minus 1 X naught X
plus h X plus zero I've just ran out of
space but you can see what I get sure
enough
yep think about where you began
think about where you'd be going so if
you see this if you say if you see three
on a four on five if that's what you saw
you really can't know whether that's 3/4
divided by 5 or 3 divided by 4/5 and
they're different right they're
completely different so what you have to
think about like this is this is bad you
should never ever see that in theory I
should know that because I made this
fraction and a fraction right I was the
one who made it I should know that I had
fractions on the top to begin with not
fractions on the bottom all right so
that's why this fraction here that's the
first time becomes one fraction is that
rather than this X I should know it's
that not that right those cases you kind
of have to rely on the lines which is
not very good but that's 3/4 on 5 it's a
little bit like it's a little bit not
exactly the same as using these right
you when you got nested fractions just
like where you got nested brackets you
kind of have to look at that though
makes you feel any better you won't meet
many of those sounds Menomonee okay so
on so what in work